Donald Trump dropped an absolutely massive
chaos bomb, just massive dumps of chaos
before leaving Washington, D.C. for his Florida
resort yesterday. We already discussed that Trump
vetoed the second coronavirus relief package.
Trump tweeted threats to Iran. And Trump
continues to make completely baseless claims about
supposed voter fraud and now Republicans in the
House and Senate are apparently trying to figure
out how to deal with what they are increasingly
describing as an unhinged Trump. And of course,
with all of these stories, we have to understand
the back story. But we also need to understand
that although it may sound as if these Republicans
now accurately are describing what's going on with
Trump, they've been the primary enablers of Trump
for a very long time. And Trump has been unhinged
and continues being unhinged. So the Republicans
now saying, whoa, Trump's acting a little
bit crazy. They deserve none of our sympathy
and they deserve much of the blame. Now, I already
told you in the earlier segment that Donald
Trump's behavior with regard to trying to overturn
the election has put him at odds with his own vice
president, Mike Pence, his own secretary of state,
his own White House counsel and many other people.
Now, we're hearing from many sources that
aides around Donald Trump at the White House
are increasingly disturbed by his anti-democratic
behavior. But since Trump posted that absurd video
screed on Tuesday making all sorts of false claims
about the stimulus package and after he dropped
that chaos bomb yesterday before leaving, we're
hearing from more and more Republicans and aides
to Republicans that there is genuine concern about
what Trump is doing here. One Republican aide said
to CNN that Trump is, quote, coming unhinged. Now,
he's been unhinged for years. House Republicans
actually had a phone call yesterday to talk about
what to do about Donald Trump's bizarre threats
and his reaction to the stimulus package, which,
of course, ended up with a veto. As we already
discussed. Republican Congressman Don Bacon
says Trump has thrown Republicans under the bus.
And there are apparently also concerns that some
Republicans will bow to Trump's pressure to try
to challenge the counting of the electoral vote
on January 6th. Now, to be clear, nobody thinks
that they would have enough support to actually
make a difference and overturn the results. Mitch
McConnell has been telling Senate Republicans
do not get involved in this effort to challenge
the results on January 6th. But there's concern
about how to handle the optics if some Republicans
did bow to Donald Trump's pressure. So let's talk
a little bit more about that. There is no way that
Republicans are going to change the outcome of
the Electoral College vote going for Joe Biden.
But it is conceivable that Trump will get some
House Republicans to object to the count for Joe
Biden to get electoral votes from six states that
Biden won. And if House Republicans and Trump can
convince just a single Republican senator to
join them in their objections, theoretically,
they could force a vote in both chambers, which
Republicans and Democrats still believe would
lead to Joe Biden winning. But again, it would
look disastrous for Republicans in a number of
different ways. Those who might vote to give Trump
the presidency if such a vote were forced would be
completely humiliate, humiliated nationally. And
those who vote that Biden should be president.
Republicans might suffer the wrath of Trump
in their constituencies. Now, increasingly,
I'm getting the sense that even though these
very Republicans are the people responsible
for what Donald Trump did over the last four
years, they likely are setting themselves up,
at least many of them, to sort of pretend they
were never really on Trump's side, even to pretend
Trump sort of didn't happen after Donald Trump
leaves office and to very quickly move on and
get back to partizan business as usual. We care
about the debt. We we have to stop socialism.
We have to stop government takeovers of this, that
and the other things. But before that happens,
prepare yourselves for a very, very wacky few
weeks. And we'll have more coverage of this on the
show's Instagram at David Pakman show. And make
sure you're following me on Instagram as well at
David Pakman. And we'll take a quick break. And we
will be speaking to Mark Tushnet after the break.
Do we really need the Supreme Court? A very
interesting perspective from Mark Tushnet.